everyone
our newest hour would not be complete
without a little news al fresco
all season we've let the news desk roam
and today
we'll be inside in chicago
with this glorious chicago crew and with
me at the desk we've got a newsie from
right here in chicago she's a morning
anchor on our affiliate wbbm
cbs2
my friend audrina bigus is back
welcome to chicago i wanted to come to
the bean that was my dream to do the
news in front of it and here we are the
dream came true you totally manifested
it well the bean which is actually
called cloud gate is one of the city's
most famous sites and it was designed by
artist anish kapoor and
i have to say i was in the neighborhood
yesterday and i went to the chicago
art institute i think it is one of the
best art collections i've seen anywhere
on this planet yes
all right audrina are you ready to hit
something ready let's do it all right
let's do it
now obviously we've been talking about
many incredible sights here but fans of
pop culture there is also a must see
just 16 miles outside the city and it's
the house from home alone now the iconic
film just turned 31 and pop sugar
reports that you can celebrate it all
december with this new home alone advent
calendar
[Applause]
it comes with a little paper tree oh
whoa
i have to say i was not expecting that
and each day you can count down to
christmas with a new ornament and it's
inspired by the film thoughts audrina
yeah so i picked up one it's the battle
plan for when the robbers try to come
into the house so you get the whole plan
for how he did that masterful
get those guys out of my house so it's
fun it's fun that they do this and
what's cool about is disney plus just
did a reboot of home alone with
ellie kemper and mikey dave from
saturday night live wrote it and i think
it's going to be huge and it's cool
for kids who may not know the other home
alone the original to be able to see it
in the reboot form and maybe spark some
enthusiasm to see this classic all right
audrina your story all right so chicago
is also world famous for its comedy
we've got the institutions like improv
olympic we've got second city we know
tina fey amy poehler they became besties
here comedy so many comedy lessons
and for you to say that i mean it's a
big deal so a study finds that 200
children they took an intelligence test
and then they were asked to give funny
captions to cartoons so then a panel of
comedy experts they rated their work
they found a strong correlation they
found this link between the funniest
captions and the highest intelligence
scores so class counts might actually be
the class brain funny people
there's a sharpness there there's a
quickness there's a seeing the world
differently and whatever it is in an eq
iq test score i don't care
these are my healers on the planets i'm
glad to know though that class clowns
may not hopefully be seen anymore as
just silly people but people with great
potential audrina didn't you have some
superlatives in high school i did and
you know it's that talking about
yourself but they voted me most likely
to succeed hey
which feels so funny to say out loud and
best dressed
so yeah so you know you got to live up
to that you feel like you got to live up
to it in your adult life well audrina i
feel like we're taking the same page out
of our fashion nod so i must be doing
something right the camel is in right
now audrina you are looking hot hot hot
and it's a perfect dovetail into our
next story because it has to do with
romance we got relationship advice
from experts who say that if there's not
a spark at first
maybe you should just let it simmer
okay install reports that sparks can
grow and even when you do feel a spark
with someone it doesn't necessarily mean
they're the one
but they could just be a super charming
and masterful flirt experts say no
matter what patience might be a key feel
it out step by step the first date is
just for seeing if you want a second
audrina
this really caught my eye i would love
to know your thoughts on spark versus
cinema versus explosion where are you at
with that
we all want that explosion right but
okay so yeah i've been there where it's
gone so the spark was there but i was so
fixated on the spark that i missed some
really important i'll call them red
flags
i missed some things that if i would
have seen them and really paid attention
and honed in on that maybe i could have
investigated a little further and not
gotten so far down the line where i'm
like i miss that and i'm so i heard this
a long time ago somebody said you don't
want to fall in love you want to grow in
love oh and with that you really i it
stuck with me oh no
[Music]
oh you just changed my life
write it down live by it we are in the
city of oprah so i think i just had a
classic aha moment
all right well right now we want to do a
review
of something it's a new thing we're
doing and it's called drew's reviews yes
all right and today it's uh something
we've been told you cannot miss when you
come to chicago garrett's popcorn it
started 72 years ago i've learned by a
mom in her chicago kitchen and the
popcorn is still popped fresh every day
here in chicago and this is not your
standard popcorn today we're trying
their signature cheddar caramel mix
we've got it we've got we've got you
cannot miss it actually we have the big
tubs
now
this is my kind of portion this is
exactly what we needed today wow do you
think we have enough i'm going to get
eating
i'm like i'm already there
oh my god i want to motorboat this is
that wrong
what could i do do what you do all right
i think we need to rate this
i mean is there even a question
i mean i give it a 10.
i give it a 10-2
i see why this is a chicago staple
institution and audrina bigus i love you
thank you for giving us a big chicago
welcome
thank you everybody
thank you so much
[Music]